if you've got a boring voice you can do
something about it it's possible
Julian treasure the auth of how to be
heard your Ted Talk is the sixth most
listened to Ted Talk of all time I've
assembled seven deadly sins of speaking
here they are it's the most common
mistake I see in business in
relationships you're speaking to teams
you're trying to inspire people you're
trying to lead people build
relationships with people this is part
of your life and you've never paid any
attention to it we teach reading and
writing in schools we don't teach
speaking which is absolutely nuts we're
much Keener to be heard than we are to
listen to others what's the biggest
complaint in relationships he or she
never listens to me our happiness and
our well-being are fundamentally
affected by whether we master the skills
of speaking and listening
how does one speak with authority in
work in life in my relationships what
advice can you give me people often say
to me I don't feel confident how can I
engage with people and the answer is
before this conversation starts I've got
a favor to ask from you 74 of people
that watch this podcast frequently
haven't yet hit the Subscribe button and
nine percent of people haven't yet hit
the Bell to turn notifications on the
bigger this platform gets the bigger the
guests get so if you could do me one
favor if you've ever enjoyed this
podcast please hit the Subscribe button
and turn notifications on without
further Ado I'm Stephen Butler and this
is the Diary of a CEO I hope nobody's
listening but if you are then please
keep this yourself
foreign
[Music]
you've had a pretty marvelous unique
career and it's twisted and turned and
twisted and turned in a really
fascinating way one in which I I don't
imagine anyone could have really
predicted ahead of time
what do I need to know about
you and your earliest years to inform
the person listening to this of any
context that ended up steering where you
would end up in your life
I think I mean I was very fortunate to
have a good education
which I didn't use to the max perhaps
but I appreciated enormously
but I think from
a young age I grew up
with a confidence that all will be well
and that's I suppose you could sum that
up in the word faith
not talking about religious Faith
necessarily
although I've been in and out of that in
my life
but just a conviction that all will be
well
and I think that's an important thing
for I mean for entrepreneurs
who tend to be the people who'll take
the jump and say oh I think I'll get to
the other side whereas a lot of people
would be standing there going you know
what you do that
so when things have come along
I've been
comfortable to go with the flow to to
say well let's see where this goes I'm
sure it'll be interesting
I read that your Ted Talk
um on speaking and being heard I think
that's the one
um is the sixth or seventh most listened
to Ted Talk of all time which is
staggering because there are thousands
and thousands of TED Talks I've done one
nobody listened
um and
so I was when I saw that I thought how
much did that moment change your life if
at all
um and can you just tell me about the
decision to do that talk that day and
how it came about
well it was the fifth actually of five
talks I did
um in a row five separate teds
uh Ted Global was in the UK and Oxford
originally
and the first one I did was about how
sound effects is the four effects of
sound it's called
uh looking back at that that's a very
younger Slimmer me on stage it's quite
funny looking at it now
um nobody's ever used sound before in a
TED talk like that so they were quite
excited about it
and then I got to do the next one was
about sound and health and then one
about listening which is you know as you
know kind of a religion for me and then
one about sound and the environment the
way Architects designed for the eyes not
the ears so I had those four
TED talks to kind of practice I suppose
and become a master I suppose of doing a
TED Talk I mean it's it's a discipline
you have 12 minutes or maybe even I
think my first one was six
you can't gabble you can't cut turn cram
too much in you have to be very clear
about the big idea the why would people
be interested in this the what's the
journey I'm taking people on where am I
moving them from to
and
you need to know how to do it how to
stand on that stage on that red dot and
project it with confidence and clarity
and engage people in coming on that
Journey with you so I suppose by the
time I did that fifth one
I was more experts think in giving Ted
Talks than most people would ever have a
chance to be because I'd done four
before and that's unusual
so certainly when I walked on stage I
felt quite good on that talk and and
yeah I think I nailed it you know I I'd
rehearsed a lot and you know we can talk
about the principles of public speaking
and so forth which you know I've done a
lot of work on
but I did a good job and the audience
really responded there was a great
feeling in the room
so when I walked off
I felt that I'd actually you know done
that one Justice they didn't release it
for a year
and I thought oh maybe they didn't like
it you know but I do remember Bruno
jassani who's one of the the guys who
kind of runs Ted
in Edinburgh Castle bumped into me uh
about three hours after I gave that talk
and he said hail
and I thought ah okay well Bruno wasn't
there so obviously word is getting
around that there's some good stuff in
there and and held the acronym that you
delivered in that talk about how to to
be a great public speaker
um honesty authenticity integrity and
love correct um how did when that Ted
Talk came out how did your life change
because I'm because I know how the
algorithms work it takes some time for
things to sort of pick up momentum but
once they get going and the algorithm
says the watch time on this episode is
very very good so we're going to just
keep showing it to more and more people
so it might have taken some time but how
did how did things change for you at
that point and also your orientation
personally and professionally
yeah it took off quite quickly once it
came out
um I had long since kind of got past
watching the numbers every day you know
the first Ted Talk I did you know I was
obsessive 10 000 people watch this you
know and and I'm sure everybody does a
TED Talk start stuff like that
um
but this one clearly was it was going
ballistic quite quickly
um it went up you know in a period of
months it was in the top 20 I think
and yes it has changed my life
fundamentally really really powerfully
because
I have spent many many hours on planes
going all over the world delivering
talks getting paid to deliver talks so
my career kind of shifted from
running the sound agency an audio
branding company in the UK which is you
know relatively small business
and writing you know my first book Sound
business
I then got the opportunity to write the
second book which was off the back of
that Ted Talk I got the opportunity to
travel the world meet people
um give talks and spread the message
which is the important thing to me
because as I say I'm a listening
evangelist I I am passionate about
persuading people to start listening
um so yeah it moved my career
totally onto a different track
a track of public speaking of writing
books of being a speaker and an author
professionally
and in hindsight when you look at this
the wild success I mean the TED Talks
combined have over 100 million views now
right so that one particular talk I
think it's about 40 million views on
YouTube alone probably right I mean
Chris Anderson says because you've got
ted.com so it's got however many million
on there I haven't looked recently but
um then you add the YouTube views Chris
says whatever it is on ted.com you need
to double it to get a reasonable
estimate of the number of views embedded
podcasts and all that kind of thing
across the internet so yeah way over 100
million I think which is mind-boggling
to me
in hindsight as you look at the success
of that the very very wild you know
completely unprecedented success of that
particular video delivered in that way
on that topic what has it taught you
about why people care so much about that
video and the topic
I think that a lot of people don't feel
heard
in the world
so that that talk was about getting your
message across how to how to speak so
that people want to listen
um and I think that's a need
and it's interesting isn't it you said
the five times number is really
interesting the talk on listening has
been seen by one-fifth as many people as
the talk on speaking so we're much
Keener to be heard than we are to listen
to others and there's an imbalance there
which I think is
endemic in modern society
why do we want to be hard
um to make a difference
to forge relationships to be validated
to mean something to somebody to feel
right unfortunately which is a big human
need that I talk about quite a lot being
right is quite a dangerous thing in the
world at the moment and a lot of people
need to feel justified in that way to be
right
what is it doing doing for us at our
most Primal level to be to be heard or
to be right what is it is it helping us
to belong in a TR in the tribe is it
yeah tribe family human race and um you
know a reason for existing I suppose you
know what am I doing here and if people
are listening to me it gives me
significance that's certainly true
so I think it's it is about validating
one's self I mean I'm big I'm a big fan
of Eckhart Toller uh and his you know
theories about ego
and I think a lot of it would chime with
that you know the ego needs to be
massaged the ego needs to have
affirmation and being listened to making
a difference to people is part of that
but you know on a more altruistic level
making a difference in the world you
know you your life has affected millions
of people
um my talks have hopefully you know cast
a pebble into a pond and the ripples are
going out and lots more people I hope
are listening as a result well that's
good you know whether it makes me feel
good is another thing but it is actually
a good thing in the world we were
talking before we started um chatting
about the uh there's an irony to you
coming here today and speaking because
you've got a bit of a chest call yeah
well yes a head cold which is in my
chest so my voice is pitched down I'd
say two tones at the moment and it's a
bit croaky you know it's frustrating as
well as a speaker
because I love this instrument that we
have you know the human voice is an
incredible instrument
and it's an instrument we all play
although most of us have never had any
training or spent any time learning how
to use it really well well I have and
it's frustrating I'm now dealing with a
slightly broken instrument it's funny
because you know when I'm when my team
send me potential guests that you know
want to come on the podcast and we've
reached out to them to come on this
podcast there's a couple of criteria I
look for and one of the most important
one of the non-negotiables where we've
had the most interesting smartest people
in the world is their ability to speak
and and when I say speak I don't mean
you know how well they can you know how
funny they are or things like that I
literally mean if they're monotone we
can't have the conversation because I I
I've no I've got no data to support this
but if someone is monotoning their
delivery then I find it to be
hard to follow the story regardless
absolutely you say that you say that the
two most important things with speaking
are
the content and then the delivery and
that's what I'm actually getting to is
like that delivery point
have you got any evidence to back up the
importance of that or am I is this just
in my head that I think the well it's
another thing I asked Chris Anderson
who's got more experience of listening
to speakers than probably anybody in the
world because they do that all the time
at Ted and I said to him which is more
important content or delivery
and his answer was answer was quite
interesting he said well if I had to
choose they're both important if I had
to choose its content
because if somebody's delivering
earth-shattering content in a boring way
I can really make an effort and listen
to them and it's worth it at the end
whereas if somebody's delivering vapid
nonsense in a brilliant way it's just
irritating
actually so I I get that but I do think
they're both important I mean it is a
shame if somebody's saying something
incredibly important and they're not
using what I call the vocal toolbox you
know there's all this stuff that we can
deploy if we start paying attention to
our voice you know if you've got a
boring voice you can do something about
it it's possible
get a vocal coach work on it you know
take up a breathing practice improve
your posture just practice
prosody prosody the intonation you know
really exaggerating it I'm a great fan
of doing this it's the kind of thing
that actors do singers do
and many times for example I've I've
given talks where I've been looking at
an audience of CEOs
hundreds or thousands of them and I say
how many of you have to talk in public
Forest of Hands goes up
how many of you have had formal vocal
training three or four people
I go what this is part of your life it's
an important part of you you're speaking
to teams you're trying to inspire people
you're trying to lead people you're
trying to communicate build response
relationships with people you're trying
to move you know mountains with your
voice and you've never paid any
attention to it
it's tragic you know we we teach
reading and writing in schools we don't
teach speaking or listening which is
absolutely nuts
it's funny because I when people ask me
I always say that the most important
skill you can learn is to sell because
you're selling all the time I'm selling
right now I'm sorry I meet a girl in a
bar I'm just going to sell to her to try
and get her number I have a girlfriend I
wouldn't do that
um I'm selling in business I'm selling
to my teams I've been trying to inspire
investors to join us it's con this
caught my life is full of the sales
pitch whether I'm selling myself or an
idea or a vision or whatever
um but I've never really reflected on
the fact that the foundation of that
selling is this instrument of course
well actually even more than that below
that what's the most important part of
the sales conversation listening
it's not the speaker it's the listening
listening to understand the other person
to go onto their Island to understand
what is it what's their pain Point what
is it I can solve or help them with here
because if you can't it's a waste of
time how many times have we all had that
irritating sales conversation where
somebody's trying to sell something we
don't at all need and because they're
not listening so patter you know it can
be good but really well targeted talking
to somebody to whom we have listened
respected and understand that's a
different thing that's powerful
what what would I have to do because
there's lots of people that are out
listening to this podcast that start
their own podcast and want to be a
podcaster and many of them message me
and they want to come and sit here on
this podcast one day what are the types
of things
um you would advise someone to do with
their voice to be a to be heard
well treating your voice as a skill is
the first thing so becoming conscious
that this is a skill it's not a natural
capability just like listening is a
skill hearing is a capability listening
is a skill so I very much talk about
these two things as skills speaking and
listening are skills that we do not
teach in school or university which is
mad so we have to take it upon ourselves
because they matter you know they they
affect our outcomes in life they affect
I always say are happiness our
Effectiveness and our well-being are
fundamentally affected by whether we
master the skills of speaking and
listening
so in terms of speaking
understanding there's a vocal toolbox is
the first thing
so things like breathing your voice is
just breath that's all it is breath
moving across your vocal cords
and in order to speak well it's very
good to develop a breathing practice
maybe you do yoga maybe something else
Jane my wonderful fiance has taught me a
breathing practice which is very very
simple anybody can do it and it's called
resonant breathing which is breathing in
through your nose
and then out through your mouth like as
if you're blowing
so you can hear it and you practice that
and lengthen you count and lengthen the
in-breath and lengthen the out breath
and also we ought to be breathing from
our diaphragm from our stomach because
you know if you watch a baby breathing
it's their stomach that goes up and down
not not the chest
so just developing that I mean I wonder
people listening to this podcast when's
the last time you took a really deep
breath we tend to breathe you know just
to a fraction of our lungs like a little
bird
but with your voice
it's very important to breathe deeply
and to get into that practice also a
great cure for nerves you know if you
come on stage and you're a little bit
like this hello everybody then a big
deep breath will settle the voice right
down so it's a really powerful thing to
do that breathing practice what is it
doing then in terms of improving my
performance I've got the nerves part but
in terms of my vocal cords or
it gets you into it well what is it
Aristotle said Excellence is uh no we
are what we do repeatedly so Excellence
is not an act it's habit
so it gets you into the habit of
breathing better and deeper
and you know when you're speaking in
public there's nothing wrong with taking
a deep breath and filling your lungs
actors do it all the time I mean a
singer can sing for the most enormously
long note uh you know what's the world
record for static apnea 28 minutes
something like that lying at the bottom
of a swimming pool
on one breath
you know and that static apnea then
you've got the the free divers there are
things we can do with our lungs which
are beyond the imagining virtually and
yet most of us just breathe a little
tiny tiny breaths
so it's good for you as well to exercise
your lungs to inflate them I I had
unfortunately a few years ago
pulmonary embolism
which is quite scary and it can kill you
and that's blood clots going to the lung
they have to go through the heart to get
to the lung so that you know that's
where you can die
um and so my lungs are not as efficient
as they were before that and it's made
me even more conscious of the importance
of deep breathing of expanding the lung
capacity
it's part of being healthy apart from
anything else to have great lung
capacity is that what exercise does yeah
kind of an advertently partly yeah
absolutely releases all sorts of good
the happy chemicals into your system as
well exercise but uh breathing is very
very good for you generally and we don't
do enough of it so I've done my
breathing exercises I'm I'm heading on
to the Diary of a CEO podcast what else
would I would I have to
um do to be heard from by The Listener
what are the sort of tips or skills or
well I think variety just in general is
a very important aspect of speaking
so you talked about people who are
monotonic and that literally means One
Tone so if I speak like this through the
whole podcast it would be extremely
boring for people there's not a lot of
intonation going on there I don't get
any emotional resonance speaking like
that so it's it's just boring so
intonation the up and down of speaking
is really important
it's also crucial to be sensitive to
cultural differences in that for example
in scandalavia they have much restricted
prosody or intonation compared to say
the Latin countries where you know
people are like why is it very up and
down like this at the whole time I'm
croaking here
um I remember doing a talk in in Finland
in The Amazing concert Center in
Helsinki which was designed by a
brilliant architect called Toyota and is
acoustically unbelievable and at the end
of my talk there was a little tiny
Ripple of Applause and I thought ah
bombed they didn't like it you know
they've been America it'd be whooping
and hollering and whatever going on and
I went down for a coffee and people came
up to me and said thank you that was the
best talk we have had for some years
that's fins for you they're very
taciturned quiet people they don't get
very excited much
so unless they've had a vodka perhaps
but you have to be adjusting to the
prosody or president of the audience
you're speaking to what's prostitute
president is both intonation so the up
and down delivery which is Route One for
emotion it's it's absolutely crucial in
speaking
and it's also the rhythm of your
speaking the the gaps you leave and the
emphasis you put on words so it's
understanding how to it's not just
reading a script flat it's putting your
personality into what you're saying and
that makes all the difference in the
world
so anybody who it's interesting I mean I
have friends who run um voiceover
Studios and
actors come in to read things TV
commercials books and whatnot
some actors can read some can't
it's not a skill that everybody
possesses to be able to
read something or speak in an
interesting way that's not a script you
learn and then you really really work on
it and so forth just reading something
it's quite
technical actually you have to get
yourself out of the way
so yes working on your voice is
um
about variety it's about breathing it's
about being comfortable with silence for
example
not filling every tiny little Gap with
arms as you knows you know what I means
verbal ticks
so all of these things it's quite
important to record yourself listen back
and start to take it as a skill and as
Mastery become your own coach
effectively I mean I'm sure you watch
back your podcasts and there's always
something to learn there's always
something to look at and to say oh okay
I could have not done that or I could
have said that better or whatever it
might be and that's how we become
Masters and of course you can get a
coach a vocal coach a singing coach a
drama coach an acting coach a speaking
coach there are lots of them out there
so anybody who's
for example got restricted Timbre I mean
Timbre is the quality of your voice
and we tend to like voices that we would
describe in the way we would describe a
hot chocolate rich dark warm sweet
smooth all of those words
if that's not you listening to this when
you have a great voice but if it's if
it's not if somebody's got a thin
squeaky voice or scratchy Voice or
whatever it may be get a vocal coach it
can be worked on these are things that
normally we're in a habit the way we
speak is partly derived from our
physical being
I mean we have a body there are resonant
cavities we have vocal cords but it's
also how we use it and that's much more
important
anybody can learn to maximize their
voice and to make the most the most of
it
so that's about the instrument itself
and then how you play it what emotion
you put into it whether you're conscious
you know the thing I love most about
public speaking
it's making me more conscious in that
moment than anywhere else
standing on the stage you know I've I've
talked to audiences of 11 000 people
there's a big Spotlight there's cameras
on you you're standing on a stage 11 000
people are looking at you if you're not
conscious in that moment you've got a
problem you know so every gesture every
moment of that
is maximum consciousness of
being me and and communicating with
those people
so it's kind of like switching the light
on to maximum intensity
and I really love that that that
experience has colored the way I treat
life in general now because you know
it's my my biggest passion is to become
more and more conscious
to grow a little every day to become
more conscious every day
and speaking helps with that
I've never really talked about it before
but we um we've deleted a few episodes
of this podcast so don't worry this is a
perfect episode but what will happen is
we've had a guest come and they might be
honestly there's some cases where they
are the biggest in the world in their
industry and I can think of one
particular example where if I said the
name of the guest that we had the
episode we had deleted people would be
shocked because I believe they are one
of the biggest stars in the world they
have like 50 60 million followers online
um and then there's another individual
I'll think about who if I said the name
now everyone knows this person they're a
legend in many respects
um but we deleted that episode as well
and content is a factor but the other
factor that really really does
and result in that decision is I I think
it'll be really difficult to listen to
and I feel like I have this sense of
responsibility on a Monday and a
Thursday when we publish that even if
they don't know the name our audience
will listen and we see that in the
numbers if we publish a no-namer or a
superstar we get the same amount of
Clicks in the opening 24 hours roughly
because people are going I don't care I
trust this team to put people out there
so I just wanted to really state that
because there's I know there's a lot of
people that want to come on this podcast
there's a lot of like big CEOs that
contact us and one of the most important
things in my decision criteria is
literally how engaging they are at
speaking and from that I mean the
instrument the delivery
um so I just don't think it's funny when
you were talking I was thinking about
individuals that have said no too big
and they don't maybe I should give them
feedback but maybe that's not my place
it's literally about delivery
um so often so let's let's continue then
on the thread of of delivery you're
talking about standing there speaking in
front of 11 000 people on a stage one of
the things that I'm sure would stop most
of us from even endeavoring to do such a
thing is a lack of confidence
you've got almost a hundred thousand
students online some something crazy
like that that are all coming to do your
courses and to learn from you
confidence must be one of the first
conversations you you you have right to
get someone to be a great speaker
yeah it's important although it's
interesting to note that a lot of the
people who've given some of the best TED
Talks
like me are actually introverts I'm not
an extrovert it's not that natural for
me to do these things
and it's also true of people like Susan
Kane introvert you can stand on a stage
and you can
overcome the fear which is part of
growing as a human being I think
um doing things which are challenging
and pushing through the barriers and
doing it anyway
so yes confidence is important I mean we
could have a long conversation about
confidence because I was educated in a
top Public School
and I think one of the things that top
public schools in the UK do is to give
you an overbearing arrogance
and um to make you absolutely convinced
that you know everything about
everything
and more than that the ability to sound
convincing and to persuade people that
that is in fact the case
and it's taken me decades to get over
that at actually to discover humility
and to discover The Importance of Being
you know authentic about what I actually
can do
so yes I think
public speaking like anything else it's
like riding a bike if you do it enough
you become confident you know the first
time you or I drove a car our hands were
welded to the wheel you know we were
shaking with Terror now you drive a car
and you think about everything but
driving you know so it's just falling
off a log I've done enough speaking now
that's
I do not get frightened anymore nervous
yes nervous is good nervous gives you
the right chemicals to perform at your
Peak
so I never want to lose contact with
that
and I think that's true of anybody only
a professional footballer before a game
nerves will be there adrenaline it's
it's taking you up to the next level
once you get bored with what you're
doing
should you be doing it that's a big
question
but the confidence to do it comes from
practice and that's what I always say to
people it's part of my course you know I
talk about doing things just just doing
the thing
speaking in public
Toastmasters for example you know
they're in every city in the world you
can go and join a Toastmasters chapter
and and start speaking in front of
people that's what they do and as you do
it you become more and more familiar
with
the what goes on and that you know it
isn't actually the end of the world
nobody is actually going to stand up and
and call you out for being a useless
numpty you know you know even if you
forget your words you can actually say
I'm terribly sorry I've forgotten where
I was and everybody I mean I've seen
that happen at Ted
okay people who rely on memory which is
a very very high risk strategy to me you
know I always use slides but if you go
on stage and you've got a Memory Palace
or a chain or one of those routes and
you're like relying on that and you lose
the chain breaks and your cast adrift in
an ocean of Terror I've seen it happen
and what happens when somebody goes red
and starts shaking and says I'm so sorry
I've completely forgotten what comes
next the audience start to applaud
because they're on your side it's not
the end of the world and actually that
can make a deeper relationship than
being slick and perfect and and
Brilliant at every moment I've seen
people who are overconfident over
rehearsed where you know every one of
those gestures has been rehearsed a
hundred times and it was there for the I
mean there was a time at Ted when it was
almost a Reger to cry in a TED Talk
and I remember saying there was a talk
by uh you know an international Banker
or something about economics who halfway
through talked about his fatherhood
deceased and the tears came I thought
please this is this is like being put in
by a coach who says you've got to
connect emotionally
and it was just incongruous really so
I think it's all about being yourself I
mean that's the a of hail being
authentic
uh being yourself is fine it's so much
easier than trying to be somebody else
and having the faith that if you are
yourself and you've got a good message
that people will be with you on the
journey and will be on your side that's
certainly the case that Ted people don't
go to it's not a stand-up comedy night
where people throw things and Heckle
it's a place where people expect to
learn to be transported to be changed by
almost every talk
so the talk does that they love you on
the on the a point in hell I've come to
learn that I think humans are much
better at spotting authenticity than we
give them credit for big time I I think
so from our own perspective we think we
can blag it and we we underestimate how
um how much the viewer or the person I'm
trying to blag it to understands I'm not
being authentic
like we think we're better much better
actors than we actually are and it's
funny the one of the things that's put
this friend of mine for me at the moment
is about three weeks ago there was a CEO
that went viral on LinkedIn because he
had fired multiple members of his team
and then he had taken a photo of himself
crying and uploaded it with like a
really like sorry caption like I'm so
sorry today I had a really tough day I
had to find members of my team and as
you look at that
it just feels wrong it's almost hard to
explain it but the I think your mind
goes well he would have had to cry a
very unnatural thing to do mid crying is
to pick up your phone and take a selfie
and then to go to social media so on
that point of authenticity
um is your suspicion the same that we
people are much better at spotting
someone being inauthentic than we
believe than we understand
I think so we live in a world where um
social media and
um viral opinion spreading make it quite
hard to be truly inauthentic I mean
there's a lot of companies a lot of
individuals who do what's now called
virtue signaling
and people can spot that you know we can
we can catch the whiff of manipulative
inauthentic stances that are trying to
put us across in um the most the best
the most acceptable way whatever the
current you know meal is whatever the
current
um style is to be utterly acceptable and
socially right
so to me this is again this is part of
the human need to be right
and to be seen to be right which is
huge problem in the world right now
I think I mean we're seeing silos all
over the world the interventors have
made this way way worse where you know
you go online and you say there you are
I know I was right 10 000 people agree
with me yeah but there's a million who
don't but you don't go and ask them you
just go and find the people you agree
with in order to validate your point of
view and that is why we get these
extreme you know um conspiracy theory
silos of people who have nutty views and
are persuading each other that they're
right because they only talk to each
other they don't go and
check you know kick the tires of the
thing and check is there an alternative
hypothesis here that would be perhaps
worth entertaining so I think that's a
bit dangerous uh at the moment and it's
all about this need to be right and of
course what's the easiest way for me to
be right is to make you wrong
if you're wrong I am writer
and that is a slippery slope that's a
slippery slope of depersonalization of
dehumanization of
um bias and and hatred and you know at
the bottom of that slope is the kind of
the Isis answer to the world disagree
with me I'll kill you
so that's a dangerous slope and the
media have been contributing to that
slope you know this all this outrage
addiction that we see in the world
that's outrageous somebody's to blame
somebody should be punished and that's
all me saying yeah somebody should be
punished I'm right they're wrong
so it's this kind of ego fire that we
have Building inside of us the desire to
be the rightest person and to cancel
everyone else that's absolutely Council
Council and make people wrong left right
and Center be judgmental that's one of
the seven deadly sins I talked about in
that in that Ted Talk is judgmentalism
is is pointing the finger at people you
know the kind of parent whose son or
daughter comes home and says I got 95 in
the test and says what happened to the
other five you know this it's difficult
to be around people who are that
finger pointy
the other thing with with those with
that a point inhale authenticity that
I've come to learn actually from doing
this podcast is um there's a real cost
mentally to being inauthentic for a long
period of time and I see I see it time
and time and time again when I sit here
with people who were forced to be in the
media or who were first forced to not
forced but chose to play a role or a
character in the public eye and then
their identity became they kind of their
true authentic self became imprisoned by
this public identity that they felt they
had to keep up and then the midlife
crisis comes it's usually like 35 45
where they have some kind of burnout
blowout they find themselves in the case
of one of my guests last week just
coming home and crying every day and
having no idea why they're crying
because they'd spent a decade being
inauthentic in every interaction because
they felt they had to sometimes to
survive because of some early trauma
um and we don't talk about that enough
that and I've you know I've learned it
from doing this podcast myself as in the
most liberating thing for me ever is to
sit here in my socks in my house saying
whatever I want for three hours and
knowing that quite honestly if I tweeted
it I'd get dragged it would get quite
retweeted people taken out of context
and goes into different Echo Chambers
and they all try and
um find a way to get likes off what I've
said whereas I can sit here and say
[ __ ] anything about pretty much
anything in my most authentic self it's
like a weight I get to lift every day
um and it's been so good for my mind
but do you know what the biggest
challenge is about being authentic
what's that was knowing who you actually
are yeah good point so what are your
values Stephen it's a good question
because because you know when people
asked
I'm so scared of saying
what I think people want to hear how do
I know what my values are you write them
down you think about it what I would
what I would write down
I'm worried that what I would write down
are things that have been so deeply
conditioned to be my values by Society
well okay yeah that's worth challenging
isn't it so this is a great exercise I
mean I strongly recommend everybody does
this because not many people do you know
we just live our life in this kind of um
bumping into things making that up as we
go a long way if you have values that's
your moral compass if you have values
that's that's you tending to Define who
you are then you can be authentic what
is a value this sounds like a crazy
thing for me to say but I want to be
really clear like what is a value it's
something that you believe in that is um
what they call in business a North star
for your life it's something that you
will sacrifice to achieve so I carry
mine okay I've got four values which I
made into an acronym because I have a
terrible memory so I like acronyms the
acronym is flag so they are Faith
and that is all will be well I'm not
talking about a religious faith I'm just
talking about the sense that all will be
well because to me if I have faith that
the future will be okay it gives me the
courage to take things on try things and
find out you know it may be a disaster
but if I get to the disaster I've had a
nicer Journey than if I am always oh
it's going to be a disaster it's going
to be a disaster there you are I told
you well I've had a miserable journey
and I've ended up a disaster
so I I prefer to go the way of it'll be
okay oh [ __ ] it's not yeah but even then
it'll be okay to find a way yeah uh so
Faith the L is love
by which I mean thinking well of people
and there's a great practice that
um a very wise old friend of mine gave
me many many years ago which is amazing
um instead of walking around you know
we're in London right now well I live in
a much more remote place so you walking
around London you're always walking
through people and we have this if we're
not careful we have this nasty voice in
our head get out of my way you fatted
yet and oh you're ugly and you're stupid
and you know this kind of nasty side of
us which is doing a little monologue and
being really judgmental and critical
about people
instead of that it's cultivating habit
of saying in the head not out loud bless
you
not religiously again just bless you I
wish you well I'll leave you get into
that habit of walking around going bless
you person who just got in my way
it is amazing the difference it makes to
your likeness of being it's like walking
floating three inches above the ground
you meet people's gaze
and you might even share a smile because
you're not guilty about you or just
thinking they're horrible
you know whereas you've got this nasty
voice going on in your head all the time
you don't look at people in case you
catch their eye and they can see what
you were thinking
so love in that way wishing people well
um and of course love for family and
love for well love for life as well just
being positive you know uh the a is
acceptance which is a really important
thing to me and I tend to try and go
with the flow if an opportunity comes
along I'll try that there's a reason
that's come along so I'm not getting
into you know the secret or any of those
things but I do tend to believe that
things come to me for a reason
um you know whether it's God or the
universe or whatever one wants to say
I'm happy to go with the flow and to
accept also when things don't work you
know I don't bang my head against a
brick wall forever trying to make them
work okay that's not working we'll try
something else so acceptance and also of
people as they are that's really really
important
we spend a lot of time disparaging
people why are you like this why are you
doing this well that's the kind of tree
that person is
and you know you don't get angry at
trees for being that kind of tree so
that is the kind of person that is in
front of you except someone once said
something to you in the podcast which
plays into that they said if if you had
been through
if you'd walked in their shoes and had
their experiences you'd be doing the
exact same oh totally well let's come on
to validation in a minute the and then
the G of um flag can I guess yes is it
gratitude yes it totally is
um I you know I I don't like that catch
phrase and attitude of gratitude but it
is really important to me uh you know to
do a gratitude list when I'm feeling
miserable when I'm feeling down you know
I've got a cold yes but let's now look
at all the good things I've got in my
life you know I have a loving partner I
have two gorgeous little children I live
an amazing orkney which is a joy every
day you know there are so many things to
be grateful for
and I've got some Financial Security
I've got uh you know so much in life to
to be thankful for that way outweighs
normally the the bad things now that's
not true for everybody you know if I
were living in cursing at the moment for
example or somewhere like that there
would be a lot more to be ungrateful for
to be frightened about and so forth so
I'm not saying that in a kind of bland
way but even in the worst places
it's important to focus our attention on
the good things
because a lot of this is about where you
focus isn't it all the time reality is
huge it's all around us we don't
perceive reality we have a map in our
head
and it's up to us to select what it is
that we pay attention to
so that's you know it's very much the
same as as listening which is selecting
certain things to pay attention to and
then making them mean something
well it's the same with gratitude
there's always something or usually
there's something you can focus on and
say okay there's a thing I can be
grateful for
so that's it yeah Faith love acceptance
gratitude so those are mine and I know
that's my moral compass and that's what
I try to be in life and I do recommend
to anybody listening to this if you've
never written your values down
think about it not the ones that you
think will be accepted by more people
out there the ones that actually ring
true in your heart what does your heart
tell you and then you've got a map uh
you've got a you've got a root you've
got a direction in life which I think is
incredibly important quick word from my
sponsor guys
um these days as I'm sure a lot of you
know flexibility matters more than ever
before because the tectonic plates in
which we've built our businesses are
changing overnight especially for SME
business owners which is why I've
partnered with Vodafone business who
have created a new flexible Business
Solution for small to medium-sized
businesses called Vodafone pulse connect
this package includes all of your
keycom's tools like mobile broadband
Cloud calling and collaboration and the
brilliant thing about it is you can
change your package as your priorities
shift adding and removing users and even
tailoring services to each employee so
you only pay for what you need and that
is so important when you're trying to
run an efficient business you can build
your personalized package online with
the digital configurator so you get one
simple package with one bill saving you
time and saving you money so to find out
more such Vodafone pulse connect terms
and conditions apply for
a point about um if you were in their
shoes you if you'd live their life you'd
be doing the validation yeah yeah what
is this validation uh well it's part of
active listening so you know if we talk
about listening
um I talk about listening positions
and one of those is active listening so
it's a place to listen from
and inactive listening to me there are
three stages so stage one is reflection
where I repeat exactly what you said
without coloring it without making it
make sense in the way that I understand
but I say something along the lines of
okay what I just heard you say is which
can be a bit formulaic or you know so
you said this or so are you saying this
so I'm checking that I actually got what
you said I heard you it's amazing how we
don't very often do that so stage one is
reflection
which is used in the therapeutic
professions a great deal
I hear you say this
stage two stages of being a great
listener it's a very important form of
listening it's not appropriate all the
time to be an active listening
um because it's kind of a sledgehammer
to crack a nut in Social conversations
for example you know if we were sitting
in a in a pub or a coffee house and I'm
going what I heard you say Stephen is
this well and then validation goes um
okay I understand it makes sense that
you would feel that
I totally get why you would think that's
true I disagree with you but I
understand why you think that because
then I'm thinking about your background
and your road to this conversation and
we've come different roads to this
conversation and you will have different
life experiences
so validation is really important that's
the empathy bit of active listening and
once I've reflected and validated
then we're into stage three which is I
can contribute
so as opposed to me invalidating yeah oh
don't no that's nonsense to you why
would you think that you know we do so
much in validating in the world of other
people's positions and you can't sell to
somebody or persuade somebody if you
invalidate them as a human being
it's really important to validate
to show that you understand where that
person is coming from even if you
completely disagree then we can start to
put things together and make sense and
move forward I'm thinking of every
romantic conflict I've ever had but also
I you took me back to many client
meetings where the client brings forth a
concern or a problem
um and in that moment you even if you
disagree you know you have to show
you've accepted their concern and then
use that acceptance that place of
empathy to move them to another place of
thinking but also you know obviously the
most obvious
scenario people will think of is with
their Partners when they're trying to do
conflict resolution you know so what's
the biggest complaint in relationships
he or she never listens to me
and that's not just about hearing the
words it's about validating the other
person or invalidating the other person
and if we do that as a habit it can be
very damaging there's a thing actually
uh called stress induced audio
dysfunction s-i-a-d
which can afflict people when there's a
noise that they are exposed to a great
deal and they don't like and they
psychologically start to wipe it out
so for example my father in the later
years of his life was deaf at the
frequency of my mother's voice
and that's not uncommon in relationships
where one partner is in the habit of
hectoring
or nagging at the other partner and they
simply cease to be able to hear it
because it's a noise they don't enjoy
just like it you know it can happen to
people with industrial noise or
irritating noises
uh so it is really important not to be
invalidating somebody as a habit and we
can easily fall into that habit and it's
so powerful in relationship to be
validating people you know one of the
seven deadly sins I talk about in in
that Ted Talk is negativity
and that's a very strong habit that
people can fall into so you can audit
that how often do I say the word no or
not or can't anything negative like that
because if that's a habit that you fall
into it tends to lead to invalidating
other people a great deal I can't do
that I don't see why you'd think that
you can't be serious you know and that's
not a very nice way to behave with
people even if you don't agree even if
they are being stupid
I can see why you think that
now would you like an alternative
perspective
can I give you a different way of
looking at it that might be useful to
you
so you've said you know what you're
doing is not worthless it's not stupid
but maybe there's another way and that's
respectful I think everyone has the
experience of invalidating someone and
them then repeating themselves and then
you invalidate them again and then they
repeat themselves yeah that's called
argumentation yeah well I know it well
because I think in my previous
relationships I would it was funny
because I think I was the problem I was
definitely the the one that was
unwilling to allow them to feel heard
it's the it's the joy of listening
actually
um listening is at the heart of all good
relationships to me and if you listen to
somebody I mean what was it Scott Peck
said you cannot truly listen to another
human being and do anything else at the
same time
and I absolutely agree with that because
it's so rare in this world now we're so
distracted
um you know I I'm a big fan of near
isle's book
um indestructible yeah because we are so
prone to being distracted now I am
listening to you now you're sending a
text that's not listening that's doing
something else so it's rare that we will
put everything down
and do what you and I are doing right
now which is look each other in the eye
you know when you look when you're
listening I've got an acronym for this
um in in the book in the courses and so
forth rasa Russia which is r-a-s-a and
the r is receive and that means look at
the person who's speaking the dance of
the eyes in in the west tends to be that
the person who's speaking
looks around
as I am now you know thinking about
other things and checks back in from
time to time to see if the other
person's still listening
if you're with somebody who's speaking
and they look at you the whole time it
can become a little bit intimidating I
mean we're in a slightly unnatural
situation here so you know we're across
a table from each other which is you
know potentially conflicting
but we're you know really making an
effort to communicate here so you know
I'm looking at you quite a lot more than
I would if we were just you know in a
street or
um you know having a chat
so that's rasa the r is receive which is
pay attention body language facing the
person not feet pointing towards the
door which is always a good indication
that somebody actually doesn't want to
listen to you not doing anything else at
the same time
the a uh is appreciate which is little
noises and head Bobs and gestures you
know eyebrow raises Smiles oh really ah
those kind of things that oil the
conversation the s is
summarizing which is the word so and I
get very angry about the word so
actually it's been
totally debased in the modern world for
some reason it's become a habit for
people to start every sentence with the
word so
so what's your name so I'm John
what you're John because I just asked
you because so means therefore no you
were John before and you're going to be
John afterwards the word so doesn't I've
seen people come onto the Ted stage and
say so no I don't know who you are I
don't know what you're going to say
there is no before
um it is debased a lot but it's such a
powerful word
so we've all agreed this now we can move
on to that or in the long Corridor of a
conversation so what I understood you
just said is this is that right the old
repeating reflecting and so forth
closing doors behind you in the corridor
so you can move on and keep moving
forward
so that's the S of rasa and the final a
is ask asking questions at the beginning
during afterwards you know people often
say to me I I don't feel confident
people don't listen to me how can I
engage with people when they're speaking
the answer is asking questions and if
you're on a bit of territory that feels
unfamiliar or uncomfortable you can ask
questions that form linking that's
really interesting Stephen you just said
that How would how would that relate to
this thing I know about
so I can kind of bring the conversation
to home turf and start to feel I can
contribute something
so that's rasa and that really helps in
a conversation to direct listening and
to and to make the conversation fruitful
for both parties
so yes therefore
one of the things you said that um
reminded me of another topic which I
think is really important when we're
talking about speaking which is how to
speak with with authority I think about
all the people that are in boardrooms
and that might be a little bit Junior in
an organization and that's struggling to
be heard because they don't lack the
The Authority that a title will give
them how does one speak with authority
what advice can you give me to be a more
authoritative speaker
um in in work in life my relationships
wherever
well let's steal the situation first
where you're talking you you want to
speak to somebody who is a powerful
figure or you consider them to be
powerful
um I'm a great believer in agreements
contracts in an informal way
Stephen do you have five minutes I've
got something I really want you to
listen to
well that puts you in a position you can
either say yes or no if you say no
that's fine I won't say it now when
would be a good time
but I'll tell you a great experience I
once had on a beach in India and this is
one of the best sales people I've ever
met it was about a seven-year-old boy
and he came up I was sitting on the
beach he came and said you want Coke
and I said um you're trying to be
British not right now thank you very
much okay when you want Coke
oh uh well four o'clock at four o'clock
he was back here your Coke
I love that it was brilliant so it
taught me a lot about
um being authentic because I wasn't
being was I no I don't want to buy a
Coke from you
um and also about persistence and you
know asking the right questions and and
so forth so in the same way if I ask you
do you have five minutes and you don't I
can park it and come back another time
because it wouldn't be the right time if
you haven't got five minutes that's fine
I can respect your time but from your
point of view yes okay I've got five
minutes and you have just made a
commitment to listen to me so I have a
right if I'm talking to you and you're
off doing something else you know
answering email or something Stephen you
said you had five minutes I do
understand if you're busy when would be
a better time so there's a kind of
obligation there for you to listen to me
so that's one thing I think that's a
strategy that works very well if you're
on a meeting
and you don't feel you're the most
powerful person then again asking the
meeting for permission is a good thing
uh guys I have something that I think
really will contribute here would it be
a good time now to say it to you all
it doesn't always work but I think if
you're asking and people give you a
commitment then you have a contract and
you have a Channel of communication
that's been opened explicitly
one of the things you talked about there
is that kid on the beach with the um
Coca-Cola offering you a can of Coke
and how that kind of violates your
a inhale the authenticity piece
um it also violates the honesty
so
my question is
is there a time when one should not be
honest
well I think that the honesty needs to
be tempered with love
so the answer is it's a filter which is
the L inhale as well absolutely okay
I think that uh being dedicated to
ruthless permanent uh always on honesty
is a pretty dangerous strategy in life
because you'd be going around saying to
people you look terrible today I really
don't like you what you just said was
stupid you know it's not necessary to
say those things to people depends on
what you want to achieve I don't think
it's dishonest to withhold
judgment
and a lot of the things I just said are
opinions
and it's very important to distinguish
between opinions and facts they're not
the same thing and they're very often
confused in the modern world so opinions
that's what I think what I believe what
I judge
fact it's Saturday matter of fact we're
not going to disagree about that we can
disagree about my opinions and you know
I often say I wish that we lived in a
society where perhaps people asked
before giving opinion would you like my
opinion on that no
I had such a good opinion all ready to
go and you don't want it but we don't do
that do we we just proffer opinions and
and a lot of the time we we confuse them
with facts which leads to a lot of table
thumping I grew up in a family where
there was that confusion there was a lot
of argumentation and table thumping
because people had different opinions
and didn't accept that they could
possibly be challenged talking about
your parents talking about your mother
no my father actually he was a my father
was a massively confident and very
successful man in advertising he was you
know he was known as Mr advertising
um for some years in the 1960s
hugely confident and hugely
expressed in that way but didn't Brook
disagreement very easily
so disagreeing with him was quite
difficult
and that was certainly my experience
growing up that you had to be ready with
chapter and verse and references if you
were going to challenge a point of view
how did how did that shape you because I
think a lot about how my parents you
know my mum was sounded a little bit
like what you described earlier where
shouted so much at my dad that I I
couldn't understand how he stopped
reacting to the sound of the shouting as
a young age I remember wanting them to
divorce because I didn't like shouting
for six hours my dad would not really
shout back but um that definitely has
shaped how I communicate now but how did
it shape you that that environment well
very similar I mean I think you know my
first response to conflict is exit
it's the same strategy really and I
think probably a lot of uh quieter
people who've had the experience of
conflict growing up are pretty conflict
diverse and I think that's it's quite
important to toughen up on that to a
degree
because conflict exists all over the
place I'm not talking about physical
conflict which of course we want to
avoid at all at all times but uh um
disagreement
or somebody being crossed with us
or somebody being upset well sometimes
those are necessary in life
and responding to those in inappropriate
ways can actually really damage
relationships I mean I talk about four
leeches which undermine communication
and the fourth of those is fixing
fixing is it's not okay for somebody to
be upset around me don't be upset don't
cry don't express emotion you know uh so
it's it's a kind of smothering of
everything that goes on around
um I'll tell you a story about that my
art told me um when her little sister
was due to be born with my grandparents
there was great excitement they
decorated the nursery uh the the the
room was made already came the day off
her parents went to the hospital and she
was beside herself with excitement aged
about six
they returned no baby
never was a word said about the whole
thing because they didn't want to upset
her
and what she learned from that for the
rest of her life was you can't trust
people people don't tell you what's
going on you never know your people
aren't straight you know there were a
lot of bad lessons she learned out of
that lack of communication
the child had been still born it was a
tragedy they were upset but they didn't
share it with their daughter because
they didn't want to upset her that's
fixing
and it can be enormously damaging in
relationships to behave in that way
obviously one wants to be sensitive you
know you sit the child down you explain
in little ways perhaps starting off with
you know the baby's not coming and then
moving on to explain what happened as
the child gets older
um Jane and I had to survive uh having
uh a baby who could not survive and it
was deeply traumatic for us
um and I'm very glad to say that with
Holly we involved her every step of the
way Holly was
uh what six at the time five I can't
remember
um but we brought her in you know when
um
Little Lily was still born we brought
her in she met Lily we called Lily a
name you know we did everything we
possibly could and Holly still talks
about Lily she talks as if she can
communicate with her she she accounts
her as a member of the family so we
didn't fall into that trap of pretending
nothing had happened and fixing
sometimes people need to be upset you
know Holly was upset we were upset and
it's authentic to be upset
so I think being that averse to upset is
quite a dangerous thing in life
it's funny because when you told that
story I was engrossed
I was engrossed for a number of reasons
that exact point there when you said
that I was engrossed and I've spoken a
lot about the delivery itself of a point
and a story but um not a lot about what
it takes to design the content in a way
where you can engross somebody
what advice would you give to someone
that is
potentially you know presenting has a
pitch coming up is going to do a podcast
about how to deliver their thoughts in a
way which is engrossing
as it relates to the content itself
because I can I can Hazard a guess as to
why I was engrossed but well it's a
story yes story we love stories
storytelling is really really powerful I
mean what's the number one Ted Talk of
all time it's a talk by Sir Ken Robinson
sadly missed dead now but see a
wonderful man and at the heart of that
talk is a little story he tells because
the thesis of the talk is that we're
educating creativity out of children
that's what his talk is saying and he
tells this story about a little girl
who's drawing at the back of the class
and she doesn't normally and the teacher
goes to the back and says what are you
drawing and the little girl says I'm
drawing a picture of God
and the teacher says but nobody knows
what God looks like and the little girl
says they will in a minute
it's a classic story it takes 15 seconds
to tell it makes me laugh every time
that is his whole Ted talk in a
beautiful encapsulating enchanting story
storytelling is the best way to get any
talk across really if you can think of a
a metaphor
which matches what you're trying to
communicate to people
in a captivating story where perhaps
there's you know the classic elements of
a story there's a protagonist there's an
antagonist there are challenges there's
a journey there's a destination there's
help on the way from unexpected quarters
obstacles to overcome you can do it in a
very short space of time you can do it
as a personal story as I did in my TED
talk about uh my mum's negativity you
know that's a true story that you know
she was in hospital I took a paper in
and I said oh look it's October the 1st
and she said I know isn't it Dreadful
and I you know well if somebody's that
negative
it's very difficult to be around them
and that was a true story that I told
so it's almost like uh you could have a
little storytelling niche in your talk
you know I'm gonna can I tell you a
story and everybody goes oh yes come on
SO storytelling is a massive massively
powerful way there are books on this uh
if anybody wants to speak in a
captivating way become a good
Storyteller and it will really really
help
but the other big part of it I always
say
is
understanding the listening you're
speaking into
say that again
understanding the listening that you're
speaking into okay
because we all have unique listening
this is something it's the most common
mistake I see in business in
relationships is people thinking
everybody listens like I do
they don't
our listening is unique your listening
is as unique as your your irises your
fingerprints your voice print and so is
mine and they're different
so it's a huge mistake to assume other
people are going to receive this message
the way I would receive it
so it's a massively valuable tool if
you're speaking to one person or ten
thousand doesn't matter to say what's
the listening I'm speaking into
what's the listening I'm speaking into
who is this person
what's their listening where will it
have come from or who are these 10 000
people because in a big room you have a
Gestalt listening
which changes over time
you know that I've done talks
immediately after lunch in what they
call the graveyard slot he's a Ted
talker he can cope with that and
everybody's a bit woozy the blood's all
gone to their guts they're a bit tired
they're not very bright you know or
there's the final slot in the day just
before people are leaving when they're
all desperate to go and have a drink in
the bar or something you know there are
different listenings through the day
and different listenings from person to
person
so it's not a fixed thing and it's
important to be sensitive
and actually do you know what I've
discovered is all you have to do is ask
the question
what's the listening and you become
really good at spotting it I don't know
how it might be tiny body language cues
it might be pheromones it might be
intuition whatever it is you will if you
pay attention to it and you ask that
question consciously at least you're
respecting the other person enough to
say this person speaks really slowly so
I should probably slow my Pace down a
little bit
or this is a really really fast person
so let's be Buzzy here or you know they
might have cultural or uh they might
have political views or something like
that that you need to be sensitive to if
you're trying to achieve something
the the point as well about about
storytelling I was I was fascinated by
it because it reminded me of um
my time at Social chain we bought the
social media company
um we never had us outbound sales team
our strategy was kind of there was maybe
fourfolds but the two that are most
pertinent what I'm to the point I'm
making are personal branding and
speaking on stage so we grow our
business from nothing to tens and tens
and tens of millions in Revenue the
agency business the global business 600
700 million in Revenue never with an
outbound sales team and the the sole
thesis which I don't think people ever
realize who are trying to scale an
agency is we just told really great
stories and the best way that I can
demonstrate this is I remember my first
talk when I started social chain at
maybe 21 years old and I was in London
and I woke up on stage and I say
that's exactly why you were kicked out
of school you're incapable of listening
to anybody and you always think you know
a better way don't call me or the family
until you go back to University
and with that my mum hung up the phone
that's how I started all of my talks for
about four years I'm trying to sell you
social media advertising here and at the
end of this the presentation you would
find out what happened with minor mum's
relationship so it'd be this heart and
it would say and me and my mum have
never had a better relationship and I
genuinely you know of all the things we
did as a business I genuinely believe
that I was speaking 50 weeks a year I
was going to every corner of the world
meeting every brand our biggest brands
like Coca-Cola they all came from
hearing that exact talk with about my
mum
um
the conventional and the the normal
thing to do is to bring information
I'll give you as much information as I
can you see it in every slide deck every
pitch deck but we all know from a human
level the best part of this conversation
is going to be the stories yeah of
course it's going to be engaging people
and causing them to be curious
curiosity is absolutely fundamental in
listening now I talk about four C's of
listening which are
um compassion
for the other person for the audience
whatever it might be commitment because
it takes time and effort to listen
listening is work it's not just a
capability yes we have ears but we
actually have to put things down focus
and so forth Consciousness that you're
actually doing something now this is an
action this is not something that goes
on in the background
and curiosity
and if you can engender those things in
people
especially the Curiosity which we get
with stories especially if you start a
story and you don't finish it
come on Stephen we want to know what
happens at the end yeah yeah so you then
got the bit in the Middle where they're
all going I really want to know what
happened at the end and then you give
them the end at the at the end to
satisfy them that is a brilliant way of
engaging people
could listening to this [ __ ] and
actually that's funny because I was
actually reflecting on we I told you my
company in San Francisco has just raised
a lot of money and I broke all the rules
that I've just said it's just it's just
there's 10 slides of just information I
mean it worked but I think it's funny
because I actually thought I don't
actually care if it worked I would have
liked to do it my way yeah you know well
also because you're then kind of
conforming to the the Norms out there
which is that's where everybody does
stuff that's a deck you know I mean I
hate that word deck anyway but you know
here here let me show have you got a
good deck yeah but there's something in
in the actual design of the deck that
says way more about you than the
information ever will yeah and it's
funny because this is genuinely what's
going on in my head as he was talking
about storytelling is I was thinking
about how I should have structured sorry
for not listening but you just inspired
me to to go from this tangent in my head
cool I was thinking about how much I
should have started that deck as a story
and that would have been so much more
gripping yeah
um versus just like put your logo on the
front and then you know you waffle into
like stats and figures I broke my own
rule there and I'm kind of disappointed
my own personal philosophy which I
consider to be the most important thing
for not doing that it's a struggle for
me as well I mean I'm writing a book
right now about sound and what I'm
trying really hard to do is to get human
stories into it you know but I have a
terrible memory and when I read great
books by people I mean I I read you know
books by people who've written amazing
books about all sorts of different
subjects
and what impresses me is they say on
March the 5th 1992 I had this
conversation with this person who walked
you know that way and did this thing and
said this thing and I think how how the
[ __ ] do you remember with you I mean I
have no idea what I was doing in 1992.
I don't remember my childhood so it is
you know it's quite a big problem if
like me you were kind of in a miasma of
I mean it's very good because I'm a
great believer in be here now and living
in the common in the in the the current
moment living in this instant which is
all the life we ever have this instant
the the future hasn't happened the past
has there's nothing we can do about
either of them much at this instant
so being here now is really important to
me
but it's kind of become an excuse almost
for me for getting everything I do too
imagine imagine how many I have the
privilege of sitting here with the
smartest people in the world who are
giving me all these amazing things so
you're massively wise yeah you would
think so but I sit here and I go oh my
God flag I'm gonna write that down later
and then we get an hour and a half in
and I'm just my it's like I've got this
short-term memory yeah the thing I I
fall back on is I go the best stuff will
stay with me because it will help me in
such a deep emotional way that I won't
be able to forget so maybe I'm just
absorbing the very best well maybe and
also you do have the privilege of having
recorded it all in high quality video
and audio so you can watch it back I
don't always have the time to watch all
of them yeah but in the gym I try and
make sure I listen to them What would
life be like if we could watch back
everything that we've done all the
conversations that we've had and learn
from them blimey pretty scary yeah
I'd be a lot better as a of a human
being me too I know I tend to see life
it's it's a spiral staircase so the
important thing to me is to grow a
little bit every day that's the
important thing to learn something you
know even if it's how not to do
something
so you know when I meet people that
evidently are making a mistake or doing
something wrong it's okay I learned not
to do that doesn't work very well
why have you struggled to grow
um but you have continually intended to
uh I would say uh in my nutrition more
than anything else probably I am very
fortunate to live with Jane who is a
four-time world champion martial artist
a health and fitness expert I train with
her multiple times a week so you know
I'm a 64 year old man who can easily
touch his toes and uh is you know my
core strength and my flexibility are
amazing for somebody of my age
but I still eat too much I really enjoy
food and unfortunately not always the
right food I think that's again you know
that's something that comes from our
upbringing from our childhood where food
was very much a part of our family and
it was a reward and it was um you know
my mother was a very very good cook as
well so there was always too much of it
and it was like a trough with me and my
brother sort of having huge helpings so
um I'm I I became acclimatized from a
very young age to having huge helpings
of not necessarily very healthy things
it's a tough one isn't it to adjust
one's upbringing and relationship with
food in that way so kale is good really
okay I have to kind of really learn some
of those things and get away from Habits
which have been with me for 60 years or
more it's so deeply emotional though and
that's what we don't really ever
appreciate we think it's just a a
decision yes or no but it's actually
such a deeply emotional thing all of
these things are yeah um deeply
psychological so I actually I was funny
I was talking to my friends about this
the other day and I said I think if you
will because we're all trying to get in
shape and we're working out together Etc
um and my one of my friends was like
well I'm gonna go on a diet I was like
the problem with that is it's not
sustainable what you're doing there is
you're you're depriving yourself you're
actually sacrificing something you want
to do how do you get I said I think that
the best way for all of us to get
healthier is actually to go see a
therapist
you know what you just said I absolutely
resonate with because Jane's always
saying to me that many times with
clients they come in and it's more of a
therapy session than a physical workout
because they're talking as they're doing
things and it's the talking that helps
them more than perhaps the exercise or
at least as much so you know I do get
that and and adjusting one's whole
psyche to see things that were perceived
as treats in childhood as not really
treats and things that were perceived as
punishments or um you know really
negatively in charge of your Hail yeah
exercise go for a run do something you
know these things are actually good for
us and they're really important to do
it's funny because there is a sound
Associated to food yeah in the sense of
just a from a psychology or an emotional
perspective you know sweets
it always sounds like that well the
sweet rapper's crinkle for a reason oh
yeah and so the crisp crisp packets are
crunchy for a reason uh because if you
had crisp packets in soggy you know
rubbery rubberized containers you
wouldn't think the crisps were going to
be fresh or as nice so the sound of
packaging certainly has a big effect on
the way we perceive taste I mean sound
and taste are very Associated I've never
heard broccoli said with excitement but
I've heard McDonald's and sweets yeah
and Coke you know yeah but also from a
marketing and branding perspective you
know Brands like Coca-Cola spend so much
of their time trying to associate even
a bottle so sound has been used in
advertising for many many years in a
very profitable way I think the first
sound was Wheaties way back in about
1926 and it was a four-part barber shop
quartet who had a little song so have
you tried Wheaties and it massively
revolutionized the sales of Wheaties and
from that point on it's been huge and
appetizing
it was only a few years ago that I got a
ston to the term
audio branding and then I got really
obsessed with it because obviously
running a podcast people are listening
to our podcast every week it's in their
ears there's certain sounds they're
familiar with there's even certain
sayings at the start the podcast where I
say I hope nobody's listening for you
I'll keep this to yourself they've
become accustomed to
um what is what is it to have a good
audio brand and how does if because
there's multiple CEOs and brand owners
that are listening to this that have
never considered the fact that they have
an audio brand as well how does one go
about doing that is it important
well the first thing to say is that all
businesses all organizations and all
brands are making sound already
because I've had a conversation lots of
times with marketing directors or CMOS
where I've said you know this is how
powerful it is and they go oh maybe we
should start doing some sound you
already are it's just not designed it's
accidental it might be the sound of your
delivery trucks pissing people off at
four o'clock in the morning might be the
sound of your uh your on hold music or
your automated call handling system
press one for this press two for that
you know nine levels later you're still
going those kind of sounds can really be
damaging and can lose
unbelievable amounts of money for a
business I mean how many times have we
slammed the phone down in frustration
that one of those systems which is
designed by a technical person not a
marketing person
um which doesn't I mean older people
hate them and we have an aging
demographic in every Western Country so
they're becoming less and less popular
so sounds like those can be enormously
damaging the sound of your corporate
reception the number of corporate
receptions I've walked into where
they've got a TV been on the wall with
news on and I remember you know when 9
11 happened I walked into the reception
of mechanics and in London they had big
TV screens with burning skyscrapers on
them
how are you expecting to have a good
meeting when you inflict that kind of
thing on people I suppose it's supposed
to say we're current and we're up to the
minute and we're you know in tune with
the world's events but news generally is
bad news I think it's unthinking yeah it
is someone just said put something on
there if you have a screen in reception
they have something playing about your
company that's informative that engages
people not you know news especially not
commercial news which may have ads from
your competitors showing in your own
reception so those kind of sounds I
think are very mindless there's a huge
amount of mindlessness about sound we
design for the eyes largely and it's not
that often that companies think about
designing with the ears
so very often you have a company that
spends masses of money on visuals
whether it's a retailer you know like a
supermarket and doesn't think about the
appalling sound of checkout beeps and
trolleys clashing and some awful tinned
music coming across on tiny little
loudspeakers that were never designed to
play music and so forth you know the
cacophony that you and I have to go
through a lot of the time in life which
is
the result of people not designing what
brands do that well
do sound well yeah generally
well
I think that Airlines and airplane
manufacturers and car manufacturers are
getting very good at it in terms of
Designing the Sonic experience of using
the airplane I mean there is an
unbelievable noise on the fuselage of an
airplane traveling at 500 miles an hour
and inside you don't hear it so the
design in there is very good and the
same with cars these days most of them
sound very good although there's a thing
with electric cars we have electric cars
at slow speed they're very silent and it
can be dangerous so you need a noise to
warn people the car is coming
um and you know a lot of the time they
make a nice chord or something like that
as they're moving through
um brands that have great powerful Sonic
logos there are plenty of those you
think of Intel for example down down
which is something you know if I say to
people can you sing intol's logo lots of
people can if I said to you can you draw
Intel's logo
no not really
squarish thing isn't it or something
that sound which was designed by a guy
called Walter was our is worth hundreds
of millions of dollars to Intel and
brand value
and they have batteries of lawyers who
approve any tiny change to it because
it's a it's a trademark for them and
it's a really important one that's
consistency right because we've heard it
so much yeah is there anything else
other than consistency for people that
are thinking about their sonic signature
and their content in their podcast in
their brand videos whatever is the is
there anything else other than just
making sure people hear it a lot
yeah so well if you're going to hear it
a lot it has to be not irritating as
well and there's there have been some
pretty irritating Sonic logos but I mean
if you think back we talked a moment ago
about the history of advertising and
sound through advertising I can remember
from my childhood so this is addressed
to your older listeners uh things like
the fairy liquid jingle you know four
hands that do dishes those kind of
things that was from 1965 or something
and I still remember it right now so
there there are things that can be
enormously iconic and Powerful uh from
the the the Tony the Tiger there great
those kind of things which last for
years and years and years there's been
at least five Tonys saying that it's
gone on so long they've kind of all died
off and been replaced
um is there an emotion to even though
it's a jingle we talked about earlier
how storytelling implants it into your
brain in a way that information can't is
there a certain emotion to the sound or
the jingle that is important big time
because sound effects has four ways and
this is a conversation which is really
interesting to me I mean it was my first
Ted Talk it's not the most watched of of
the TED talks and it's something which
is
um the reaction I get from people is is
often the same it's well that's
absolutely obvious but I never thought
of it I've never been conscious of it
you know we're very very ocular in the
Western World particularly and we're
very oriented around the eyes there are
loads of Design Awards in the world
they're all for how things look
there's no Design Awards for how things
sound it's it's bizarre architects
are all about how things look very often
and they design things that sound awful
and aren't fit for purpose because they
look great and that's all they care
about
so
it is very important to become sensitive
sound changes your body
physically so for example I could
entrain your heartbeat if you go if I
drop you in a nightclub with pounding
dance music at 140 beats a minute your
heart rate will immediately increase or
if there's a sudden sound
you got me yeah so your heart rate just
jumped because you had a shot of
cortisol your fight flight hormone and
noradrenaline and that gets you ready to
fight or flee so your heart rate your
breathing your hormone secretions your
brain waves they all get changed by
sound
that's the first way sound changes your
feelings think of music it's the most
obvious example but for me you know my
favorite sound in the world is the sound
of rain on leaves outside the window
Summer Rain on leaves outside the window
well that's enormously calming to me
other people it might be gentle surf or
something like that so sound can affect
our feelings bird song makes people feel
secure
because the birds have been here far
longer than we have and we've learned
over hundreds of thousands of years so
when the birds are happily tweeting
things are safe we're okay
if they suddenly stop you need to be
worried because Birds stop it there's a
big Predator like a lion okay
then the Third Way sound effects is how
well you can think cognitively you know
we are all completely used to the the
would you be quite I'm trying to think
here especially people's conversations
the most damaging sound of all it's
really difficult to think which is why
we are one-third as productive in open
plan offices as we are in quiet working
spaces one-third
if we're trying to do knowledge working
you know manipulate
words or numbers in our head and write
for example so I have friends at the BBC
you know the BBC have gutted that entire
building in Portland Place and it's now
got a basement where they all sit
writing with it four floors of space
above them
and it drives them nuts if you're a
journalist trying to write a story and
you're finding on a deadline and you've
got people around you talking it is
really difficult to concentrate
so that's uh in terms of cognition how
well we can think is affected by noise
around us or sound around us
um
and finally sound changes our Behavior
it changes what you do and what I do
every day
there's a brilliant study actually which
was done some Years Ago by some
academics they had a supermarket with
two Gondola ends French wine on one
German wine on the other one visually
identical and all they did was to
alternate the music so day one you had a
bit of French or accordion music day two
you had a bit of German kind of umpire
music and they kept doing that for an
extended period of time
on the French music days French wine
outsold German wine by five bottles to
one which may not be surprising it does
sell more in the world so okay we might
expect that but
on the German music days German wine
outsold French wine by three bottles to
one
now that is a massive shift in behavior
and that's not people coming in going ah
German music therefore I shall buy a
bottle of German wine they were they
weren't even aware of the music most of
the people who were surveyed they hadn't
noticed so this is unconscious response
to a sound situation that's how much
sound is changing our behavior all the
time and so part of my message part of
my my whole thrust and the difference I
want to make in the world is to get
people listening consciously
so that we start to become aware of the
ways in which sound is changing our
bodies Our emotions our thinking and our
Behavior so we can start to take
responsibility for the sound we consume
and possibly even more importantly
responsibility for the sound we make
with our voice
and you know also willy-nilly inflicting
sound on other people possibly unkindly
uh which very often happens also
everyone listening to this podcast you
know and I even imagine the title that
will work best when we do our a b tests
will be about how to be a great speaker
we've talked about why that is why we
all want to be heard more it gives us a
sense of significance helps us to feel
valued which makes us part of the tribe
and all of these things but you as as we
said at this very start of this
conversation you really are leading a a
crusade to get people to listen more why
should that be the title of the podcast
why is that potentially even more
important
um to the world and if we all started to
listen a bit more why would the world be
such a better place personally and
globally because I think with conscious
listening the result is always
understanding
and that's what we need
understanding in the world de phrase
conflict it means that people can
co-exist side by side with people with
whom they disagree and we've seen the
way that's not happening in the
polarization of politics for example in
America where it becomes
a hated thing for somebody to disagree
with your views uh you know that we're
seeing such polarization in so many
countries now and that's all about this
thing of being right and not listening
to other people not not trying to learn
anything but becoming more and more
entrenched in a set of opinions which
you know they may be useful to you but
is that true is that universally true
would you Brook any kind of
antithesis to that any kind of counter
view any competing solutions to the
world how can you grow if you are stuck
in a bunker
and you're listening through a tiny
little slit of an entrenched listening
position that I'm writing everybody else
is wrong certainly on this issue
so to me a passion for listening is
about coexisting with people
I don't agree with I may not like but
they have a right to be here and they
have a reason there's usually a good
reason for what people think or what
people do often
and you know I'm not saying
pity the mass murderer and so forth
necessarily you know there'll be
possibly reasons for that as well we
certainly need to understand them to
stop it ever happening again
so listening even to people like that I
think there's things to learn I mean how
could you ever become like that and why
would you ever behave like that
so if we just dismiss people that we
don't approve of or people we don't like
then
we don't learn very much at all so I
think listening is you know I said this
I did a tedx talk in Athens the Cradle
of democracy and I went on stage and
said listening is the sound of democracy
because without it it's very hard if I'm
the minority
it's very hard to accept the majority
view isn't it you're all wrong and I'm
gonna fight well that is just a recipe
for recipe for Anarchy conflict War as
we've seen
whereas if I can say okay I can
understand why you all think that I'll
try and change your opinion but you know
I'm not de-personalizing you I'm
understanding that you're human beings
you have a different view from me and I
can see why you got to that view
then I can grow you can grow we can
possibly come to some sort of synthesis
thinking a lot about modern listening
there and the tools we have to listen to
each other one of them being social
media yeah one of the things that's so
tempting to do for all of us which I've
refrained about two years ago I made a
very conscious decision to
to do this but I used to just unfollow
people that
I didn't like what they said so like I I
wouldn't follow Trump for example or
like Nigel farage or like people that I
thought were just idiots who had
ulterior motives whatever I would just
unfollow them and what I'm the problem
with that approach is I was as I saw
other Echo Chambers emerging online is
that I wasn't progressing in any way I
was as you've said it like I was
increasing the size of my information my
exposure therefore my ability to have
empathy or to understand people out that
didn't think like me so I did a I
started following people who were who I
who made me feel uncomfortable it's the
best way to describe it yeah well
uncomfortable is a call for reassessment
isn't it yeah and that's really
important but I do think social media
has got a lot to answer for in the way
that it's been abused by people
um with trolling and particularly with
shaming there's a brilliant talk by um
John Ronson who's who's become a friend
of mine over the years on social media
shaming and if anybody hasn't seen that
I do recommend you watch it because it
is truly chilling to recount how a mob
can beat somebody out of their job for
what was originally quite an innocent
post
so we now see this you know we see slurs
being um unacceptable words being
labeled on top of people uh who find it
difficult to defend themselves whether
we're talking about racist or we're
talking about homophobe you know at the
moment that person is labeled with that
thing it's very hard to get the stain
off isn't it and then you get a mob who
go on and start castigating the person
without ever understanding what caused
this in the first place
so I think we've got to be very careful
about the way these things are used and
without listening to the person and what
their views really are
it's all too easy to get into a kind of
knee-jerk mob Lynch Mob kind of
mentality where we're being right it
comes back to that again doesn't it and
that person is wrong and must be
punished or shamed or canceled or
whatever it may be so I think listening
is really important and as you say to
people who make us feel uncomfortable
well that's a warning sign that perhaps
we need to reassess or analyze or what
is going on here why is this making me
feel uncomfortable is it actually
against my views or my values or is it
against my social conditioning and would
my friends disapprove of me if I thought
that that kind of thing I'd love to live
in a world where we um we all including
myself we're much better at listening
and also accepting ideas that made us
feel uncomfortable that's in part what I
think we're trying to do here is to have
conversations to see ideas Collide that
help to move the the world forward
um
and I only started thinking about that
the other day when we had a guest on
called Africa Brook that maybe that's
ultimately the the net benefit of this
is just Fearless conversations in a
medium where no one's going to be edited
or or cut down and manipulated that will
hopefully push the conversation forward
and I'm not right and my guests are
sometimes it's just all opinion
um we do have a closing tradition on
this podcast where the previous guest
asks a question for the next guest they
write it in the book
Jack gets to see it I don't get to see
it
um until now so give me a second to read
it they don't know who they're writing
it for
and you will also be asked to do the
same I have been dreading this moment
really why it's so funny that everyone
gets really nervous now yeah and I'll
just say you know everyone takes a long
time to answer but then they also take
an even longer amount of time to think
of a question to write okay
okay
this person wrote see they've really
given themselves away but
I have played sport for a living
I've presented I've done acting
and I've sang songs
but I would still love to do one more
thing with my life
what's your one more thing
I think for me
um I've resisted doing a lot of
um
things that I know intellectually are
really really good for me
so I can probably crystallize that we
haven't in Scotland where I live we have
a thing called Monroe's
these are a set of Peaks
I think they're over
3000 feet or something like that I can't
remember how big they are but they're
you know it's sizeable and
um
I saw an amazing story the other day
about an 83 year old man I think who has
just completed climbing all of the
monroes there are a lot of monroes
you're talking about more than a hundred
and he's just completed that I mean
these are serious
uh schleps you know and at his age he's
just completed it was a wonderful
picture of all his friends with walking
sticks forming a kind of
um Corridor for him to walk through on
his final complete
um
I would love to take on doing at least
one Monroe a year
as a walk Jen and I have just got into
serious walking where we live in orkney
and we did Eight Mile Walk the other day
and I was virtually crippled the
following day I couldn't move so I'd
love to get to the stage where I get my
body used to that kind of thing it is so
beautiful to be out in the fresh air to
be in beautiful scenery to be exercising
my body in that way to be losing weight
to be becoming fitter I mean it's just
nothing but good from the whole thing
and taking it on to do it up on Monroe
that would be a serious challenge for me
so one a year for the rest of my life
would be fantastic
amazing and I'm gonna find out if that
happens so me and Jane are gonna stay in
touch fair enough
um and maybe I'll come do a couple of
the monroes with you because I've got
increasingly um interested in like
hiking we'd love it lately so do invite
me if you do end up doing it but um
definitely thank you so much for your
time today thank you Stephen you've
given me so much from through your
content and the videos and especially
the TED Talks you've made me it's one of
those conversations that we've had today
but also from watching your videos where
I start to reassess all of the as I
describe it like the unthinking I've
done with sound I just haven't thought
about it enough and it through this
conversation I even thought about our
little jingle at the start of the Diary
of a CEO which we've always had since
episode one and to be honest I've never
really thought about it it's just been
there and it's and that kind of
reassessment because I completely agree
with everything you've said about the
importance of sound but if I agree then
why aren't my actions
and my why isn't it such a high priority
in the way that I'm thinking and
designing the things that I create so
yeah
and also everything you've said about
conflict resolution and relationships
and the importance of that sound plays
there it's such an important
conversation one that I hope we can
continue long after this podcast but I
just wanted to say thank you for your
time today thank you for listening
that's a yeah it's a lovely way to end
thank you for speaking and thank you for
listening it means the world to me thank
you thank you Stephen
I had a few words to say about one of my
sponsors on this podcast my girlfriend
came upstairs yesterday when I was
having a shower and she said to me that
she tried the heel protein shake which
lives on my fridge over there and she
said it's amazing low calories you get
your 20 odd grams of protein you get
your 26 vitamins and minerals and it's
nutritionally complete in the protein
space there's lots of things but it's
hard to find something that is nice
especially when consumed just with water
and that is nutritionally complete and
that has about 100 calories in total
while also giving you your 20 grams of
protein if you haven't tried the heel
protein product do give it a try The
Salted Caramel one if you put some ice
cubes in it and you put it in a blender
and you try it is as good as pretty much
any milkshake on the market just mixed
with water it's been a game changer for
me because I'm trying to drop my calorie
intake and I'm trying to be a little bit
more healthy with my diet so this is
where heel fits in my life thank you
heal for making a product that I
actually like The Salted Caramel is my
favorite I've got the banana one here
which is the one my girlfriend likes but
for me salted caramel is the one
[Music]
thank you
[Music]